(audience cheering)
- I love that we kind
of match a little bit.
- We kind of match.
- It's like we called each other.
I saw you back there and
I didn't see your pants.
- Yeah, man.
- I was like, "Oh."
- Cream, you know?
- I know.
- Earth tone, whatever.
- It's a nice...
I'm feeling very earthy.
- Yeah, as am I.
- How's your summer going?
- Summer's fantastic-
- Yeah.
- Right now.
- And time off?
- Got a little time off.
- Got a project coming up
later on in the summer,
which I'm really excited about.
But in between times,
spending time with the family.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Gonna go to Germany.
- Love Germany. Where?
- I'm going to Dusseldorf.
- Okay.
- Do you know it?
- Yep.
- So I'm going, because
my son is a footballer.
I have to call it a footballer
because he's actually soccer here.
- [Kelly] Like European football.
- European footballer, right.
- [Kelly] I like the
accent, everything going on.
- [Sterling] Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
I get right into character like that.
- [Kelly] Damn, very thespian.
- Thank you.
(Kelly laughing)
Acting, no.
He's going to this camp in
Germany so he gets to play
international competition and stuff.
It's a big deal.
This club soccer thing.
- That's huge in Europe, yeah.
What an honor to get to play with him too
because it's just such
a huge thing culturally.
- It's massive.
- Way more so than here.
Which I grew up playing soccer
but no one cared about soccer.
- I grew up playing soccer too.
But you play soccer until
you can play football.
Like you're Texas.
- I played until I played volleyball.
- You got it.
- So, wait, is there any other,
I know one of your son is
into to European football,
but your other son is into
something really cool.
Like Fencing?
- [Sterling] He really is.
- He's gotten into fencing as of lately.
- That's really cool and very posh.
- It's very posh and he'll come
up and he'll like attack me.
He'll be like on guard and
he'll do his whole foot thing.
Look at your feet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He does this whole thing
and I said, bro, keep it up.
This will get us into college.
Like fencing Yeah.
Is one of those niche
things that every college
there's like those places are looking for.
Yeah. Fancy schools.
- Stick with it.
- Yeah
- And what a cool thing, to
randomly wanna do fencing.
That was never even an
option when I was growing up.
You know what I'm saying?
What a thing.
- Neither was it for me.
- But isn't cool that you
work your tale off though,
and your kids get this
opportunity that we never have.
- It's the best thing.
- Yeah.
- Quick anecdote. To see your
children pass you in anything,
is always a great moment.
- Yeah.
- My kids play chess.
I play chess as well.
- You are a fancy ass family.
- We try to be that bougie,
black sort of thing.
- I'm like, we hold down Scrabble.
- I hold down some Scrabble.
- Okay!
We'll rock some connect four. - Okay!
Like we go all over the place.
But my kid, my oldest will
like come close to beating me.
he hasn't beaten me yet.
- Oh, I love that you don't let them win.
I can't stand when parents do that.
They need to know how to lose.
- So when he gets that dub,
he knows he earned that joint.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yes.
- Yeah. But it's getting there.
- Oh, that's gonna be a
really proud moment for you,
when he kicks your butt.
- And also going to be sad. -
And also like a tough moment.
It's going to be both of
them at the same time.
- I know. I'm looking forward
to that for him personally.
Thank you.
(laughing)
So wait, you just went back to St. Louis
to give the commencement speech.
- I gave. Yes.
- Do you get nervous
doing stuff like that?
I mean, you're an actor so I
know you can maybe play a role
if you want to and not
be nervous about it,
but that would terrify me.
- It's the writing of the speech that's
the most terrifying part.
- Oh.
- Because you know what
it's like to graduate
and be in that audience
and not give a flying fig
Newton of what anybody says.
I just want to go drink.
- What party am I going to?
- You know what I'm saying?
I'm about to go kick it real hard.
- Yeah.
- So try to come up up with something
that sticks to people's ribs.
- Yeah.
- A little bit. That's
all I'm hoping that I did.
Hopefully I accomplished that.
- Yeah. That's really cool.
- Thank you.
- Well, I know that St. Louis is big,
but John Ham, Cedric
the entertainer Nelly,
there's so many people from St. Louis.
- We got a few folks from the Lou.
- Did you ever know any of them?
Like beforehand?
- I know a lot of people
will know each other
and then they...
- We know each other now.
So I'd met Cedric the entertainer before,
because my wife's godfather
was his financial planner.
(audience laughs)
Random right?
At a small town.
- It's so random.
- So that's how I know Ced.
- okay.
- And I knew him before any
sort of fame came my way.
So he's a good, good man. Good person.
John Ham, went to my
competing high school. Right.
- Oh, so you met up him with like sports.
- But, he's a little bit older than me.
I'm not trying to put him on blasting.
- Oh, you just did though.
I kinda liked it.
(laughing)
- I wasn't on purpose.
This don't crack, but
he's a little bit older.
(kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
- He's a little bit older than your boy.
(laughing)
- Just a little bit older.
That's amazing. That's awesome.
- Yeah, so we hadn't met.
We'll get the text thread going soon.
Nelly is from like the
neighborhood right next
to my neighborhood in St. Louis too.
- Yeah.
I've never met him, but we'll love to.
- Oh my God. He super nice.
I met him randomly very quickly.
I met all three of them.
They're all like such gentlemen.
- Yeah.
They're very, very cool
dudes. - Yeah. Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- So we've mentioned your work
with the organization Survivorship Today.
So for those who don't know,
can you explain what it is?
- Survivorshiptoday.com
is a website hosted
by Bristol Myers Squibb,
and it's about people surviving cancer.
- Yeah.
- I got involved because
my uncle passed away
from pancreatic cancer some time ago.
But thankfully people are
living longer with cancer now
than they were when he passed away.
So it's a form where people
can share their stories
of how they got to and
through survivorship.
And it's such a big thing
Kel, because I think when
people get that diagnosis, it
can be incredibly isolating
and very lonely.
And to know that there
are people out there...
- And scary
- And scary, yeah.
To have gone through
what you've gone through
and can share their stories.
At least you have an instant
sense of community and you know
that you're not going
through this by yourself, so.
- Yeah.
That's what it's there for.
- Going through anything alone is,
I think that's the most devastating thing
about being a human.
If you're experiencing something
alone and feel isolated.
I can't imagine getting news
like that and feeling alone.
Not what to do,
not knowing what to do.
- It made me think,
this is not cancer by any stretch,
but when the pandemic first happened.
If you're in a house by yourself,
you have your children,
I have my children and my wife.
I couldn't imagine just being alone.
- Now sometimes I did dream of that.
(laughter)
During Covid.
Okay. So your new movie Biosphere?
- Yes.
- Okay.
So it's it's a different kind of survival.
But I love anything survival.
I'm into this stuff wholeheartedly,
but without giving much away
because I know that you
can't tell all of it.
- The spoilers. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- You don't wanna spoil it
- I don't wanna spoil it.
- Tell everybody a little bit about it.
I mean Biosphere,
so you're stuck inside
something with another...
- There you go. That's it.
- Okay.
- There's some sort of
unexplained nuclear fallout.
- Okay.
- We built something that we could survive
this nuclear fallout.
So it's just two guys and we
think we're the last two people
on earth as far as we know.
It's heartfelt.
- Yeah.
- There's comedic elements to it.
- I imagine
- There's sci-fi elements,
obviously because it's a
unexplained sort of universe.
But there's a really
lovely payoff in the end.
I wish I could tell you more.
Watch it though, because
I'm in it with Mark Duplass,
who's a great human being
and we have a wonderful time together.
- I mean, here's the thing too though.
It's all about chemistry, right?
- Yes. - Of the people
you're working with?
So, what was that thought
like that you're like,
okay so I'm gonna play
this role with this person
that I don't know.
- Right.
- And, if we don't like each other
this is gonna be a not a fun shoot.
- I love when Texas comes out of Kelly.
(laughter)
- It's so small.
I love it.
(audience applauds)
Makes me really, really happy.
It's gonna be a fun shoot.
- I'm just saying...
- Listen...
It's like listen, how
long will I be stuck here?
- Here's the thing.
It happens all the time in acting.
- Yeah.
- So many times you'll show up,
there may be some sort of
love scene in the movie.
- Yeah.
- And they'll be like,
all right so first up is this love scene.
And you're like, I don't know her.
And she don't know me.
Why am I doing this the first thing.
- I'm sweating.
- And so as it's starting
I'm like, Hey, how you doing?
I'm Sterling, taking off my clothes.
I'm like, if there's anything...
So it ain't like that.
Okay. I knew him a little
bit longer than that.
- Okay.
He's a the kind of person
that is easy to know.
He's an that's an open book.
- Yeah.
- He has two children.
I have two children.
He has a wife who's an actor.
I have a wife who's an actor.
So we have we points of commonality
that we can connect to really quickly.
- Yeah.
- And he's also the kind of person
that if you ask him a question
he's gonna give you an honest answer.
And I'm the same sort of way.
- Yeah.
- So when people are open like that
you can build chemistry pretty quickly.
- Yeah.
- Well if you had to be stuck,
I hate to ask you this question
cause I know you're gonna ask me.
If you had to be stuck in a room with just
one person and it wasn't
your wife or kids,
- Wasn't my wife or kids,
do my wife and kids exist?
- Oh, that's an important question.
Because I know where
you're going. (laughing)
- Because I wanna know,
is sex on the table?
Is sex not on the table?
(audience applauds)
- Wait a minute.
- If I'm in a room, I need to know.
- I just changed, I
just changed my person,
if sex is on the table
(laughing)
- You know what I'm saying?
- I was like thinking survival.
And then I'm like, wait, wait, wait.
- Right.
- There's another kind of survival.
No, it's, anything.
(Kelly laughing)
It's humanity at it's finest.
- Yes.
- Let's say none of our families exist.
You just stuck in a room and
you have to choose someone.
- All right.
Well, okay.
If sex isn't on the table,
I'm gonna pick my best
friend Phillip Grant,
who I've known since I was five years old.
(gasps)
- That's awesome.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah. Since kindergarten.
- Now, can this person help you out?
Are they a survivalist?
- He is.
- Okay.
- I'm not a super handy guy.
- But he is like DIY all day
long, so he can fix stuff.
- Okay.
He's a good cook, too.
- You'd pick him and
he'd pick someone else?
(laughing)
- No, cause I can entertain.
- That's amazing.
- I'm good for a chuckle.
Yeah, so that would be him.
If sex was on the table,
I'd pick somebody else.
- Yeah, me too.
So if sex were on the table, definitely.
That's not on the table.
I honestly think I'm
going to pick my sister,
because this is why,
we didn't actually grow up together.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. Dysfunctional American family.
But anyway, but we are so
similar and I think I'd pick her
just because I think we
are able to be very honest
with each other.
- Yes.
- Look, I need a minute.
- Yeah.
- Without you in it.
- Right.
- You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
But also, we can both build fire.
We're like survivalist people.
- Really? - Were you girl scout?
- Yes, I was a girl.
(audience applauds)
Yes. I love all of that.
I have every book.
If you ever came in my
house, you'd probably be like
she might have a problem.
I think it's fun.
I love Biosphere.
I'm totally into this kind
of concept for a movie, show. everything.
- So, basically you're
telling me if it happens,
I'm coming to your house
- I tell all my friends,
because none of those
(censored) are prepared.
Yeah.
I'm like, yeah.
I'm like, everybody's
gonna come to my house
so I gotta have enough for everybody.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, no, I'm that person
you'd want to be stuck in a room with,
because I'm I'm pretty handy.
- Okay.